ZDF heute live euch ein herzliches
willkommen zu unserem wöchentlichen
Ukrain Update an einem denkwürdigen
Nachmittag für die Ukraine denn soeben
ist folgende Meldung eingetroffen dass
Präsident selenski sein Militärchef
saluschni entlassen hat vorausgegangen
waren tagelange Machtkämpfe zwischen
beiden und dann vor wenigen Augenblicken
dieses Foto das selenski gepostet hat
auf seinen Social Media Kanälen zu sehen
bei mit seinem ja bis dato Militärchef
und darunter dann dieser Text wo
saluschni so heißt es sich bedankt für
zwei Jahre Verantwortung für die Ukraine
und der Ukrainer alles Gute wünscht und
sich ja Sieges sicher zeigt und schreibt
dass die Ukraine gewinnen wird es sind
Abschiedsworte von saluschni und darüber
wollen wir ganz aktuell reden mit
unserer Korrespondentin oder Reporterin
besser gesagt eine Brühe die für uns in
Kiev steht hallo Anne zu dir nach Kiev
erzähl uns wie überraschend kam das
jetzt ja das war schon überraschend
irgendwie dann auch nicht weil es gab ja
schon diesen Machtkampf der zumindestens
ganz offen seit Montag abend letzter
Woche geführt wird es gibt übrigens auch
schon einen Nachfolger für saluschni
general sirski das hat selenski eben
gerade bekannt gegeben das ist der
Armeechef er ist verantwortlich für die
Trupp
im Osten er gilt als sehr erfahren er
war unter anderem auch an der
Verteidigung von Kiev in den ersten
Kriegstagen beteiligt und dann auch bei
der Verteidigung der Großstadt harkiv im
Osten da standen die Russen ja auch in
den Vororten also man setzt jetzt hier
auf einen Neuanfang und selenski
versucht alles damit das positiv nach
außen wirkte du hast eben gerade die
Zitate genannt das waren die Worte von
selenski die er an saluschni gerichtet
hat und es gibt eben dieses Foto zwei
Männer selenski saluschni der alte
Oberbefehlshaber die sehr freundlich in
die Kamera lächeln die sich die Hände
geben und das ist glaube ich ein ganz
wichtiges Signal weil natürlich ist
dieser Krieg in einer entscheidenden
Phase das hat auch noch mal gerade der
Verteidigungsminister umerov gesagt der
hat gesagt der Krieg verändert sich und
er verlangt nach Veränderungen und
solche Veränderungen sind jetzt eben
vorgenommen worden und ich glaube es ist
trotzdem ein wichtiges Signal dass das
in einer positiven Stimmung passiert
selenski sagt ja immer wieder wir müssen
an den Sieg glauben er ist jemand der
versucht positiv zu sein die Leute
mitzunehmen und in diesem Sinne glaube
ich kann man diese Art dieser
Veränderung und diese Entscheidung von
heute dann auch
interpretieren ja die Inszenierung wirkt
zumindest am Ende dann doch eher
verbunden und freundschaftlich du hast
das gerade schon gesagt der Nachfolger
steht fest was glaubst du wie schnell
wird das jetzt über die Runden gehen wie
geht es jetzt weiter in der
Ukraine ich glaube schon dass die
Entscheidungen jetzt getroffen sind und
dass diese neue Führung sich gruppieren
wird selenski hat da auch noch anderen
Namen genannt also das ist ja nicht nur
die Person des Oberbefehlshabers sondern
das ist ja ein ganzes Team von Generälen
die sich natürlich eng untereinander
abstimmen und ich habe schon gesagt die
Situation hier so kurz vor dem zweiten
Jahrestag dieses Kriegs in der ganzen
Ukraine die ist natürlich angespannt
viele sind unruhig kriegsmüde es läuft
militärisch nicht so gut gerade im Osten
bei afdevka bei kopjansk wo dass die
ukrainische Armee sich einer großen
Überzahl von russischen Soldaten
gegenüber sieht es fehlen Waffen
Artilleriemunition die Luftverteidigung
das klappt auch nicht mehr so gut das
hat man hier gestern bei den Angriffen
auf Kiev gesehen also die Situation ist
schwierig und dazu kommt ja auch dass
die Ukraine ja weiter weiß dass ohne die
Unterstützung westlicher Partner dieser
Krieg für sie auch nicht zu gewinnen ist
und bei dieser Unterstützung da pröckelt
es ja auch sieehe Amerika man hofft hier
auf Europa aber jedem ist klar diese
Unterstützung die wird bitter gebraucht
und dazu natürlich eine eigene Strategie
möglicherweise auch ein Strategiewechsel
um wieder erfolgreich sein zu können in
diesem Krieg mhm wir bekommen erste
Zuschauerfragen rein Anne über meil
übrigens könnt ihr uns die stellen und
über unsere Kommentarspalten wie immer
bei ZDF heute live da interessieren
viele ähm die Reaktion im Volk zu
selenskis Entscheidung jetzt ist diese
Meldung so frisch dass du da
wahrscheinlich nicht groß was zu sagen
kannst wie die Menschen da jetzt drauf
reagiert haben in den letzten Tagen und
auch ganz aktuell gab es aber
Großangriffe gerade auch auf Kiev und du
hast das gesagt dein Eindruck ist dass
die Menschen schon sehr kriegsmüde sind
jetzt nach dem zi Jahren und kannst du
eine Einschätzung geben gerade auch
jetzt nach diesen Großangriffen auf Kiev
die es jetzt gegeben hat wie groß diese
Belastung ist und bringt jetzt diese
Entscheidung selenskis vielleicht auch
ja dann den erhofften neu auch für die
Menschen ja ich würde vielleicht ich
gerne als erstes auf diese
Zuschauerfrage Antworten also die
Unterstützung für saluschni die war groß
er war sehr populär er hatte große
Vertrauenswerte größere sogar als
selenski und wenn man hier den Leuten
zugehört hat dann war da in den letzten
Tagen auf der einen Seite Unterstützung
für für saluschni zu hören aber auf der
anderen Seite hieß es auch immer es ist
wichtig dass eine Entscheidung getroffen
wird und diese Entscheidung ist jetzt
gefallen und ich glaube das wird von
vielen positiv gesehen und man setzt
jetzt eben auf den neuen auf general
OBAS sirski und was die Stimmung hier in
Kiev anbelangt das ist natürlich schwer
gestern war wieder eine dieser riesigen
Angriffswellen auf die Stadt es gab
Explosionen es gab vier Tote 40 verlzte
und das ist natürlich beängstigend und
trotzdem geht der Alltag hier irgendwie
weiter die Menschen die sozusagen noch
mal davon gekommen sind die wissen aber
dass Sie natürlich jederzeit die
nächsten sein können denn das ist ja die
russische
Kriegstaktik Terror gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung also aus dem Schlaf
gerissen zu werden vom Alarm des
luftalarms
Explosionen zu hören in einer Großstadt
die Menschen sitzen dann in ihren
Wohnungen können oft gar nicht in Bunker
weil es in den Häusern eben keinen
Bunker keinen Keller gibt also das ist
ja hier eine russische Taktik den
Menschen hier im Land klar zumachen es
kann jeden treffen überall in diesem
Land aktuelle Einschätzungen live aus
Kiev von Anne Brühl Anne ganz lieben
Dank zu
dir und damit schalten wir weiter nach
München dort sitzt unser Gast Nico lange
Militärexperte und Politikberater für
außensicherheits und
Verteidigungspolitik er ist uns
zugeschaltet aus den Räumen der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz schön guten Abend
zu Ihnen Herr
Lange
Abend selenski feuert sein bis dato
Armeechef der Nachfolger steht fest was
ist das für ein Zeichen für die
ukrainische
Truppe zunächst mal ist es gut dass die
Frage geklärt ist es ist ja Unsicherheit
produziert worden und das ist natürlich
in die Truppe hinein schlecht jetzt ist
es klar saluschni ist weg sirski ist der
neue Oberbefehlshaber und für die Truppe
ist es so dass sie den General sirski
lange
kennen der ist im Donbass äh schon ein
wichtiger militärischer Führer gewesen
seit 2014 der ist jetzt der Armeechef
der hat bei der Verteidigung von Kiev
eine leitende Aufgabe gehabt bei der
Verteidigung von rakiv also das ist
jetzt niemand ganz Neues auf den Sie
sich einstellen müssen was bedeutet das
militärstrategisch salusni war jetzt 2we
Jahre für die Ukraine als Armeechef im
Einsatz ähm jetzt von heute auf gleich
kommt der kommt ein Neuling äh daran
geht das so einfach militärstrategisch
um zuändern diese Planung
ja man kann schon zwei Unterschiede
erkennen ich glaube es war schon vorher
so dass
Präsident selenski mit General sirski in
manchen Fragen eher übereingestimmt hat
als mit General saluschni und dass er da
vielleicht auch weniger Widerspruch
gekommen hat und General sirski ist
glaube ich jemand der die russischen
Streitkräfte sehr gut kennt und meine
Interpretation ist dass das in dieser
Lage in der die Ukraine im Osten sehr
unter Bedrängnis steht darauf ankommt
jemanden zu haben der in der
Verteidigung sehr gut ist also die
Ukraine ist gerade nicht in der Lage
komplexe Angriffsoperationen zu führen
sondern muss sich mit unterlegenden
Ressourcen im Osten verteidigen und
sirski hat auf diesem Gebiet besonders
viele Erfahrung das mag vielleicht ein
Grund sein warum er jetzt der
Oberbefehlshaber geworden ist mhm vielen
Dank erstmal für diese ganz aktuellen
Einschätzungen Herr Lange unser
eigentliches Thema dieses Ukrain Updates
äh sollte sich eigentlich mit der
sogenannten elektronischen Kriegsführung
beschäftigen ein Aspekt zu dem sie
gesagt hatten jüngst in einem Interview
dass es ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt sei
aber dass dieser ja doch bislang
unterschätzt wurde und zwei Methoden
zeichnen diese elektronische
Kriegsführung bislang aus die erste ist
das sogenannte blocken das bedeutet der
Verteidiger zerstört hier die Navigation
von Waffensystemen oder Drohnen macht
sie damit für den Angreifer unbenutzbar
die zweite Methode hier wird die
Navigation mit elektromagnetischen
Strahlen auf eine falsche ferte gelenkt
und die Drohne der Rakete findet ihr
Ziel dann nicht
mehr das sind ja bis dato Stand der
Dinge ein weiterer wichtiger Aspekt zu
dem wir reden wollen sofern ihr dazu
Fragen habt an Nico lange könnt ihr uns
alles gerne schicken wieer Mail oder die
Kommentarspalten her lange erklären Sie
uns kurz wenn sie sagen dass es ein
wichtiger Aspekt der bislang ja eher
unterschätzt wurde oder nicht gesehen
wurde auch Präsident selenski hatte
gesagt die oberste Prio der Ukraine ist
diese elektronische Kriegsführung was
zeichnet diese dieser Aspekt so genau
aus warum ist das so
wichtig wir haben in diesem Krieg seit
Beginn des Krieges gesehen dass Elemente
der Kriegführung die in gewisser Weise
neu sind eine ganz hohe Bedeutung
gewonnen haben also zuallererst die
Drohnen die wirklich überall im Einsatz
sind aber auch die digitale Verb bung
auf dem Schlachtfeld das Nutzen von
Daten das Nutzen von
Satellitenverbindung wie starl und
anderen aber mit dieser zunehmenden
Bedeutung dieser Methoden hat die
elektronische Kampfführung also das
stören genau dieser
Methoden der Kriegführung an Bedeutung
gewonnen und Russland hat in den letzten
Jahren und Jahrzehnten in zwei Dinge
besonders investiert in Raketen und
marflkörper und eben in elektronische
Kampfführung und deswegen ist s da sehr
leistungsfähig und wenn wir z.B
Satelliten naavigations äh Munition
liefern die mit Satellitennavigation
gesteuert wird also mit GPS und die
Russen sind in der Lage diese Munition
zu stören dann äh treffen die Raketen
heimmaßraketen z.B oder
präzisionsartillerie dann treffen die
eben nicht das Ziel dann ist unsere
Hilfe verloren viele Ressourcen sind
verloren und die russischen Streitkräfte
können sich wehren und Russland ist da
immer besser geworden in den letzten
Monaten in diesem Krieg und deswegen
muss die ukrainische Seite da unbedingt
gestärkt werden und hinzu kommt noch ein
Aspekt in der Auseinandersetzung mit
sehr vielen Drohnen hat elektronische
Kampfführung eine sehr starke Bedeutung
weil man darüber herausfinden kann wo
die drohenoperateure sind man kann die
drohen übernehmen oder zum Absturz
bringen oder man muss seine drohen eben
sehr stark Härten gegen elektronische
kampfführungsversuche der anderen Seite
und diesen ständigen Wettlauf sehen wir
jetzt auch
die Russen sind dort sehr leistungsfähig
man sagen sogar dass die Russen einige
Systeme haben die leistungsfähiger sind
als die der NATO insofern besteht da
dringender Handlungsbedarf sie haben es
gerade schon leicht angesprochen es ist
den Russen auch ja in den letzten
Monaten immer wieder gelungen die unter
anderem aus Deutschland gelieferten
ähm Raketenwaffen abzuschießen oder
sozusagen zu deaktivieren erklären Sie
uns kurz wie genau funktioniert das
russische System hat es der Westen
vielleicht
unterschätzt
ja also es haben viele gewusst dass
Russland da sehr leistungsfähig ist aber
in den ersten Monaten des Krieges war
Russland nicht in der Lage diese Systeme
einzusetzen und Russland ist im
Kriegsverlauf besser geworden und zeigt
jetzt seine Leistungsfähigkeit auf
diesem Gebiet deswegen muss man jetzt
darauf reagieren
dass Russland solche Dinge kann war
bekannt aber für die Partner der Ukraine
gibt's ein großes Dilemma gerade in dem
Bereich der elektronischen Kampfführung
sind die Dinge die wir haben unsere
Waffensysteme unsere jamming Systeme die
sind mit sehr sensibler Technik
vollgestopft vieles davon ist geheim und
man will natürlich nicht dass man das an
die Ukraine liefert und dann fällt es
den Russen und in der Verlängerung auch
den Chinesen in die Hände das ist ja
auch für unsere Sicherheit zumindest ein
Risiko dass man Abwegen muss ich glaube
aber über diese Frage muss man noch mal
nachdenken wenn man erreichen will dass
die Ukraine sich verteidigen kann und
sich auch durchsetzen kann es gibt erste
Experimente damit westliche Bauteile
westliche Systeme mit
ukrainischen Systemen zu verbinden
sogenannte frankensteinsysteme und auf
diese Weise hat man schon viel erreicht
z.B iranische Shahid drohen kann man
mittlerweile damit zum Absturz bringen
also auf dem Gebiet muss noch mehr
passieren aber es gibt
aufhollbedarf Stichwort
Sicherheitsgarantien der Bundeskanzler
hat sich heute auf dem Weg nach
Washington gemacht zu einem Kurzbesuch
ähm nächste Woche findet die 60 Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz statt wie können
die nächsten militärischen und
politischen Schritte aussehen wenn sich
die NATO jetzt schwer tut ihre
hochentwickelte Technik der Ukraine zur
Verfügung zu stellen auf diesem Aspekt
sozusagen der elektronischen
Kriegsführung was kann der Westen da
noch
liefern ja der Bundeskanzler ist
sicherlich in Washington um abzustimmen
was wird aus an Militärhilfe aus den USA
kommen welche Instrumente hat Präsident
Biden für weitere Militärhilfe für die
Ukraine falls die Zustimmung des
Kongresses und danach sieht es ja aus
für das nächste Finanzierungspaket nicht
kommt gibt es da noch andere
Möglichkeiten was müssen die Europäer
zukünftig tun wie kann man die Europäer
zusammenbringen es ist ganz klar dass
jetzt mehr Verantwortung bei den
Europäern nicht damit auch beim
deutschen Bundeskanzler die Ukraine zu
unterstützen in den politischen Fragen
werden sich beide sicherlich abstimmen
im Vorfeld der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz wie sie sich iieren
gegenüber anderen die sehr weitgehende
Forderung haben etwa in Bezug auf eine
Einladung der Ukraine zur
natoitgliedschaft beim Gipfel in
Washington möglicherweise spielt auch
die Frage des nächsten NATO
Generalsekretärs nächsten NATO
Generalsekretärin eine Rolle also über
all diese Fragen wird man reden ich
hoffe dass man auch darüber spricht der
Ukraine leistungsfähigere Waffen zur
Verfügung zu stellen nämlich attack MS
mit höheren Reichweiten und Monoblock
Sprengköpfen und dann auch
taurusm das Appell vom Kanzler war heute
klar mehr
Militärhilfen aus dem Westen für die
Ukraine das hat er kurz vor seinem
Abflug heute noch mal bekannt gegeben
wir können mal kurz reinhören was er da
gesagt hat jetzt ist der Moment wo wir
das tun müssen was jetzt erforderlich
ist nämlich gemeinsam der Ukraine die
Möglichkeit zu geben sich zu verteidigen
und gleichzeitig an den russischen
Präsidenten ein sehr klares Signal zu
versenden das Signal nämlich dass er
nicht darauf rechnen kann dass unsere
Unterstützung nachlässt sondern sie wird
lange genug andauern und sie wird groß
genug sein das ist die Botschaft die wir
in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen
gemeinsam aussenden
müssen sagt ein Kanzler der aufbricht zu
Joe Biden in die USA bis dato der
wichtigste Waffenlieferant und
Unterstützer der Ukraine aber aktuell
stellen sich ja die Republikaner quer
haben jüngst blockiert ein 60 Milliarden
Hilfspaket was können denn die USA dann
da überhaupt noch liefern
ja das ist die Frage was kann Joe Biden
tun wenn der Kongress die Mittel nicht
freigibt gibt es andere Möglichkeiten
über präsidentielle Erlasse über Mittel
aus dem regulären Staatshaushalt über
Mittel die in Verfügung des Pentagon
stehen also über diese Frage wird
gesprochen werden müssen aber natürlich
ist das jetzt auch ein gewisses Problem
dass der deutsche Bundeskanzler sich
dafür entschieden hat sich immer nur
eins zu eins an das Weiße Haus zu hängen
und genau das zu machen was dort auch
gemacht wird wenn jetzt aus den USA
weniger kommt dann ist ja die Frage was
ist die europäische Rolle kann man die
europäische Rolle stärken und kann man
auch Dinge liefern die die Amerikaner
bisher nicht nicht geliefert haben also
das ist gut mit Joe Biden zu sprechen
aber ich glaube mir mindestens genauso
wichtig wenn ich jetzt noch wichtiger
ist es zwischen Bundeskanzler Scholz
Präsident macron den Staats- und
Regierungschefs in Italien in Spanien
den Briten zu besprechen wie die
Europäer jetzt viel stärker viel
schneller der Ukraine helfen wenn es mit
den Amerikanern schwieriger wird
zumindest auch das eine aktuelle Meldung
ein Zeichen aus den USA kam ja jetzt
noch sie hatten das letzte Woche bei uns
in der Sendung auch schon angekündigt
diese sogenannten glsdb das sind
präzisionsgesteuerte flügelmunition
Hightech Waffen die da jetzt noch in die
Ukraine geliefert worden ist das
vielleicht noch mal eine Chance für die
Ukraine diese hochspezialisierte
russische elektronische Kriegsführung so
ein bisschen zu
umgehen na zumindest
kann Russland seine wichtigen Assets und
dazu gehören auch Systeme für die
elektronische Kampfführung nicht mehr in
einem ganz schmalen Küstenstreifen am
asofschen Meer in Sicherheit halten weil
jetzt die Ukraine mit glsdb die
Reichweite hat 150 km um da jeden Punkt
in diesem gesamten von Russland
besetzten Streifen zu erreichen und mit
dieser Munition sehr präzise zu treffen
das werden die Ukrainer ganz sicherlich
auch Unternehmen und dann kommt bei
glsdb hinzu das ist eine amerikanisch
europäische Gemeinschaftsproduktion die
Firmen Boeing und SAB Stellen dieses
System her das wird direkt von den
Herstellern in die Ukraine geliefert das
kommt also nicht aus dem Bestand der
us-stitkräfte das kann man auch machen
ohne Zustimmung des Kongresses da kann
man sogar überlegen ob z.B die Europäer
mithelfen diese Lieferung zu finanzieren
also das könnte ein Einstieg sein in
einen neuen Weg der Militärhilfe für die
Ukraine genau dann schaue ich mal was
unsere Zuschauer so fragen Arthur
Fritzler fragt wie stehen die Aussichten
russische Geldmittel im Westen von rund
300 Milliarden Euro für die Hilfen der
Ukraine
einzusetzen ja das ist nicht so einfach
zu beantworten es ist leicht zu sagen ja
das ist sinnvoll diese Geldmittel
einzusetzen für den Wiederaufbau der
Ukraine und für die Unterstützung der
Ukraine in den USA wird ja auch gerade
ein Gesetzesvorhaben zu dem Thema
besprochen aber in den Details ist es so
diese Mittel liegen ja z.B in belgi
in anderen Staaten und dort gilt
nationale Gesetzgebung die ist von Staat
zu Staat sehr unterschiedlich und es
wird sehr schwer sein für alle Staaten
dort Entscheidungen zu treffen so dass
die Mittel genutzt werden können
möglicherweise gibt es eine Möglichkeit
die Erträge also wenn dieses Geld
angelegt ist die Zinsen dort daraus die
Erträge zu nutzen für die Ukraine das
wäre immerhin schon ein Schritt nach
vorne oder diese Gelder als Sicherheit
zu nutzen soass z.B Kredite ausgegeben
werden können mit der Sicherheit dieser
Mittel im Hintergrund über all diese
Fragen wird gesprochen ich glaube das
wird ein wichtiges Thema sein auf der
nächsten großen wiederaufbaukonferenz
für die Ukraine für die Deutschland die
Verantwortung hat und die in Deutschland
stattfinden wird zu Beginn des Sommers
vorher steht aber die 60 Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz in der kommenden
Woche an Sie werden das für uns
natürlich auch mit verfolgen ähm mit dem
Statement heute was selenski da gesetzt
hat äh dass er seinen Armeechef gefeuert
hat er wird ja nächste Woche dann auch
mit dabei sein und soll auch eine Rede
halten was glauben sie wird diese mün
münchenner Sicherheitskonferenz bringen
für die
Ukraine ich glaube es geht um ganz
wichtige Fragen für die Ukraine sowohl
militärisch als auch politisch eine ganz
entscheidende Frage ist die Auslastung
und die Erhöhung der Kapazitäten für die
Produktion insbesondere hier in Europa
da geht's um
Artilleriemunition
luftverteidigungssysteme Lenk Systeme
lenkfugkörper für die Luftverteidigung
und über all diese Dinge wie man das
schneller mehr produziert muss jetzt
umso mehr gesprochen werden das wird
sicher ein Thema
sein die weiteren militärischen Themen
sind sicherlich die Frage wer hat
eigentlich noch was in den Lagern kann
man noch mal nachgucken kann man noch
mal tiefer reingreifen um der Ukraine
jetzt in dieser schwierigen Lage wo sie
insbesondere ja im Osten extrem unter
Bedrängnis ist schnell zu helfen und in
den politischen Fragen geht es jetzt
schon sehr stark um den Blick nach vorn
die Ukraine ist breitittskandidat für
die EU die Ukraine will sich der NATO
weiter annähern und es wird für den
Gipfel in Washington die Frage aufkommen
kann man die Ukraine in die NATO
einladen was bedeutet das genau was sind
da die Möglichkeiten stärkt das die
Allianz also diese Fragen werden ganz
sicher hier besprochen werden in München
in einer Woche Einschätzungen vom
militärrexerten Nico lange Herr Lange
vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit heute
Abend
gerne und danke auch wie immer an euch
für euer Interesse und für eure Fragen
Meinungen und Anregungen das war ZDF
heute live für heute wir sagen tschüss
und bis ganz
bald